what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have a lot of exciting news today
to talk about in the Marvel world we
have some Venom 3 News some Deadpool 3
news but most importantly we have some
Captain America 4 and World War Hulk
news which I know fans are really really
excited about now most probably know but
if you don't know by any chance Captain
American 4 has had a title change it
used to be Captain America 4 New World
Order and now it is Captain America 4
Brave New World also another thing that
is very important to know about the
information we're about to speak about
concerning the Hulk is that the rights
for the whole cap come back to Marvel
Studios from Universal basically Marvel
Studios before this could not make a
solo Hulk film that is why you always
saw the Hulk in team-up films you saw
him with Thor and Thor Ragnarok which
was basically a Hulk movie as well and
then the Avengers films basically before
Universal were the only ones who could
make a solo Hulk film anything else by
Marvel Stadium videos had to be a team
up film that is not the case anymore
Marvel Studios can make a solo Hulk film
and they are making one now they're
about to really set this up in Captain
America 4 Brave New World and don't
forget they also did start to set this
up already with She-Hulk the very end of
it introduced Bruce Banner's son scar
which is already kind of deviating from
the comic story of world war Hulk but we
knew that was going to happen we know
Marvel Studios doesn't adapt the comics
page for Paige in fact most of the time
they are just simply inspired by the
overall story arc of the comics and for
the most part change a lot of it and
that is of course because we would know
exactly what was going to happen if they
just simply copied the comics now we
know that a World War Hulk movie is
coming or at the very least a solo Hulk
film we're not sure if they'll actually
call it World War Hulk but we have been
getting reports from insiders over the
past year basically stating that it's a
World War Hulk story and we found out
recently that it actually might be
coming a lot sooner than we think now
not too long ago on June 15th variety
reported that they can confirm that the
rights to the Hulk have gone back from
Universal to Marvel Studios this means
Marvel Studios can start working on a
Hulk movie right now in fact they could
have already begun to work on a Hulk
movie in preparation of them getting the
rights to the Hulk back in fact the
ending of She-Hulk does show us that
they clearly have plans for the Hulk and
they're gonna do a whole story based off
of him and probably his son as well so
it wouldn't surprise me if Marvel
Studios has already been working on a
script or an overall story or the solo
Hulk film already and two days ago
Insider Casey Walsh responded to a tweet
stating I'm told Captain America 4 as a
movie that will follow its events this
could be World War Hulk but I have not
confirmed it here's the thing though
this lines up with what many insiders in
the past have said that Captain America
4 is going to set up what they are
calling World War Hulk again we're not
sure if that's the official title for
the solo hope project but main point
here Captain America 4 will set up a
Hulk movie and if we think about what
might go down in Captain America 4 it
does make a lot of sense Thunderbolt
Ross is back now being played by
Harrison Ford in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe due to the unfortunate passing
of William Hurt but also Elizabeth Tyler
is reportedly coming back in this film
as well as Betty Ross who we all know is
the love interest of Bruce Banner so we
can already see the connections forming
with the Hulk before the movie is even
coming out now of course we know
Thunderbolt Ross has wanted super
soldier serum Hulk serum for a pretty
long time and right now everybody is
looking at Harrison Ford wondering if
he's going to turn into Red Hulk in this
film right now many of us are assuming
of course just due to the nature of
everything but nothing is 100 yet
however many insiders have stated that
we are going to see more than one
variation of the Hulk in Captain America
Brave New World and no I don't mean we
are going to see a multiversal variant
of the Hulk in this movie movie we're
talking about other variants like Red
Hulk and maybe some other hulks that
come about due to experiments from
Thunderbolt Ross and this is how our
Hulk could be brought into Captain
America Brave New World or how the solo
Hulk film could follow up this movie
dealing directly with the events that
have happened in this movie because
Thunderbolt Ross is Red Hulk himself and
is going about creating other hulks
basically still at it with his
experiments perhaps we could even get
another Abomination since the
abomination in the MCU right now is
pretty chill and is pretty occupied with
the many girlfriends that he has if he's
gotten out of jail already but what's
interesting is that a World War Hulk
storyline in the MCU is looking to be
not really anything like the world war
Hulk storyline in the comics based off
of all of The Insider info that we've
heard so far World War Hulk is looking
to be like a big battle between many
different hulks most likely the hulks
that might be created in Captain America
Brave New World because the traditional
World War Hulk storyline doesn't really
seem seemed to be fitting with the
events that are going to take place in
the MCU anytime soon in the comics the
Illuminati are the ones who decide that
the Hulk is too dangerous to be kept on
Earth so they trick him and send him
away he ends up landing on sakar and he
ends up basically ruling it he gets a
wife she gets pregnant and then the ship
that the Illuminati sent him there
explodes killing his wife and his unborn
child so from there in his massive Hulk
rage he comes back to Earth and
basically defeats everybody he even
forces all of the heroes to go into a
Coliseum and fight each other that is a
super summary of what happens in World
War Hulk if you have not read that I
suggest you do it's amazing and a must
read for Marvel fans and if you want to
check it out you can check out my
buddies over at comicbookdirect.com they
have created a website and company that
makes comic book shopping the easiest it
can possibly be they deliver Comics
straight to your door you can get
one-off Comics or you can sign up for an
entire run and get a pretty big discount
if you do so and those ship the latest
issue right to your door each week they
have the latest from Marvel if you're
trying to keep up to date with all the
recent projects they have the latest
from DC as well and it's an all-in-one
shop for your Comics everything that you
need in one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below now we've already seen Hulk
on sakar and he's already made his way
back in fact he went back to sakar after
and came back with the Sun so again for
World War Hulk we are most likely
looking at a battle or a war between
many different versions of Hulks which
could definitely be an amazing movie if
done correctly of course and again this
movie following up on Captain America 4
makes a lot of sense as well if
Thunderbolt Ross is still trying to
experiment with Hulk serum and if he
becomes Red Hulk he could be one of the
main hulks in that Hulk movie which I
would be extremely excited for but go
ahead and let us know your thoughts
about that in the comments down below
but like I mentioned we also have some
Deadpool 3 news and some Venom 3 news we
just got some set photos from the set of
Venom 3 and it looks like they're
shooting in Mexico right now and it
looks like they're going to have a Day
of the Dead scene or Dia de los Muertos
as we can see in these set photos things
are decorated for the Day of the Dead
and if you recall in the post-credits
scene for Spider-Man no way home that is
where Tom Hardy's Eddie Brock and Venom
left off they did go to the MCU for a
very brief moment but they came back and
where did they go back to presumably
Mexico because in the Venom 2
post-credits scene that is where Venom
and Eddie were they were in a Mexican
hotel watching a Mexican soap opera so
perhaps the beginning maybe the entirety
of Venom 3 takes place in Mexico where
we will see some scenes celebrating the
Day of the Dead which you can imagine
could be pretty interesting for Venom I
am definitely very curious to see how
they handle that scene and as far as the
Deadpool 3 news is concerned it seems
like we have a confirmation of the
Fantastic Four the old Fantastic Four
with Jessica Alba are indeed going to be
in the film The Insider account my time
to shine hello tweeted a few days ago
mommy's back and we found out from The
Insider Casey Walsh that she was talking
about the invisible woman presumably
talking about Jessica Alba being mommy
this was rumored and speculated about
for a pretty long time but now since two
insiders are seemingly confirming this
it looks like it's pretty much official
Jessica Alba as The Invisible Woman and
we are assuming the rest of the
Fantastic Four from the original
Fantastic Four will be returning as well
and this hopefully does include Chris
Evans as the Human Torch something that
we've been waiting for for a while and
Chris Evans himself actually did say
that would be pretty cool to return as
that character in the MCU somehow well
this is definitely how it would happen
Deadpool 3 being a multiversal film
makes it entirely possible for him to
return so fingers crossed on that one
fingers crossed that it isn't just
Jessica Alba returning as the invisible
woman but hopefully the original
fantastic forecast so go ahead and let
us know all your thoughts in the
comments down below let us know how
excited you would be for a World War
Hulk movie Venom 3 and Deadpool 3. and
only a handful of days left for the
giveaway all you gotta do to enter is
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment the winner gets to pick one item
in Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items as well
we pick a winner at the end of each
month don't forget to check out our
patreon account our Discord server and
our website and of course you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter as well as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf
foreign